ils étaient plusieurs milliers à
manifester dans les rues de bangkok
hier à l'appel des militants
antigouvernementaux la manifestation a
débuté par le monument de la démocratie
choisi symboliquement pour l'occasion
avant de se diriger vers le palais du
gouvernement
j'aimerais bien sûr assisté à moins de
violence et davantage de changements
vers un gouvernement démocratique
un gouvernement véritablement
démocratique peut être contrôlée mais
aussi contrer par la voix des citoyens
on peut résolument être optimiste
aujourd'hui je pense que la raison pour
laquelle les gens sont venus c'est
l'espoir même si la manifestation de ce
jour ne change rien nous avons
clairement senti que beaucoup de gens
partagent les mêmes objectifs et les
mêmes croyances
face à ce mouvement de protestation le
gouvernement hausse le ton et interdit
tout rassemblement de plus de cinq
personnes
ainsi que des publications en ligne
pouvant nuire à la sécurité nationale
des manifestations qui ont par moment
tourné à l'affrontement avec la police
dans la soirée les manifestants se sont
installés devant le palais du
gouvernement avant d'être délogés à
l'aube par la police anti émeute
plus de 20 personnes ont été arrêtées
nous avons arrêté les manifestants qui
enfreignait le règlement que j'ai
mentionné leurs actes sont considérés
comme un crime et autorise donc les
forces de l'ordre à les détenir
concernant cette vingtaine de détenus
nous allons appliquer une procédure
conformément à la loi il s'agit du
troisième rassemblement de militants de
l'année il appelle un changement de
régime à une modification
constitutionnelle et à une réforme de la
monarchie
ringuette étudiante elle est l'un des
leaders de la contestation
pour elle il est temps d'opérer un
véritable changement
je me fiche de savoir si je serai
emprisonnés ou tués
je m'en fiche je veux juste un vrai
changement dans ce pays notamment une
réforme de l'institution royale et que
chacun puisse être heureux et avoir une
vie meilleure
auparavant les gens n'osaient peut-être
pas parler de la monarchie désormais ils
le
on car quelqu'un a commencé je considère
cela comme un premier succès celui de
pouvoir repousser les limites de la
liberté d'expression sur ce sujet ces
revendications sont pourtant très
controversé à commencer par celle
remettant en cause la loi punissant tout
crime de lèse majesté de 3 à 15 ans de
prison
un changement de mentalité difficile à
mettre en oeuvre car en thaïlande la
monarchie considérée comme sacrée et
perçu comme un pilier de l'identité
nationale